solve the system of equations by
substitution check your solution by
graphing the equations so let's do it by
substitution we know that Y is equal to
this thing over here and we also know
that Y is equal to this thing over here
so they're going to intersect when they
both equal the same Y or when this thing
is equal to this thing or when negative
x squared is equal to is equal to 2x
squared plus 3x minus 6 the x value at
which these two are equal is going to be
the X values where these Y's are equal
so that's going to be their point of
intersection that is will be an X and Y
pair that satisfy both of these
equations so let's solve for X here so a
good starting point let's just add x
squared to both sides let's add x
squared to both sides and we end up with
zero is equal to three x squared plus 3x
minus 6 and then just to simplify this
on the right-hand side we could divide
both sides of the equation by three we
can divide everything by three and we're
left with zero is equal to x squared
plus X x squared plus X minus 2 we could
do the quadratic equation or complete
the square all sorts of quadratic
formula or complete the square all sorts
of crazy things but this is actually
very factorable zero is equal to two
numbers let's see 2 and negative 1 when
you multiply them you get negative 2
when you add them you get positive 1 so
this is X plus 2 times X minus 1 so that
tells us this X plus 2 is equal to 0 or
X minus 1 could be equal to 0 and so
subtract 2 from both sides of this you
could get X is equal to negative 2 or
add 1 to both sides of this X is equal
to 1 so these are our two solutions X is
equal to negative 2 or X is equal to 1
now let's verify it when I put X is
equal to negative 2
let's do it over here when I put X is
equal to negative 2 here what do I get
negative 2 squared is positive 4 and
then you get put a negative there so
it's negative
or so the point the point here is
negative 2 and then negative 4 that's
what happens when you put negative 2
there and then what happens when I put 1
1 squared is 1 and then you put a
negative there it's negative 1 so it's 1
negative 1 so these are both points on
this equation right here on this
function now if you look at this one
over here if you put negative 2 over
here let's see 2 times negative 2
squared negative 2 squared is positive 4
2 times positive 4 is 8 3 times negative
2 is negative 6 so 8 minus 6 minus 6 so
what is that 8 minus 6 is 2 2 minus 6 is
equal to negative 4 so the point the
point negative 2 negative 4 is on this
function so they both share that point
in common so the intersect there and if
I put 1 into this I get 2 plus 3 minus 6
2 plus 3 is 5 minus 6 right when X is 1
which is negative 1 so the point 1
negative 1 is also on this top graph so
we can plot these points negative 2
comma negative 4 negative 2 1 2 3 4 is
right there that's going to be a point
of intersection and then we have the
point 1 negative 1 1 negative 1 is also
going to be a point of intersection
there and let's graph this second one
let's just verify they say check check
your solution check your solution by
graphing the equation so let's graph
this first one this is pretty easy to
graph y is equal to negative x squared
it's going to intersect the point 0 0
it's going to be a downward slope
downward opening parabola when X is 1 or
positive 1 Y is going to be when X is
positive or negative 1 Y is going to be
negative 1 right because you Square and
then you take the negative when X is
positive or negative 2 y is going to be
negative 4 so the graph will look
something like this 4 5 6 7 8 9 so the
graph will look something something like
that that is that equation right here
now this is going to be an upward this
is going to be an upward opening
parabola and a quick way we could do all
the
at completing the square and all of that
but if you think about it let's let's
just apply the quadratic equation right
here and I want to show you something a
quick way of where the vertex formula
comes from when you apply the quadratic
formula so if you take this and you were
you wanted to find its zeros you would
say X is equal to negative B which is
negative 3 plus or minus the square root
of B squared which is 9 minus 4ac minus
4 times 2 times negative 6 times
negative 6 all of that over all of that
over 2 times a all of that over 2 times
2 2 times 2 now we can evaluate this and
figure out the zeros of this but the
real point why I wanted to show you this
is because we always have two solutions
so let me let me actually write down the
quadratic formula here for you so the
quadratic formula is negative B plus or
minus the square root of b squared minus
4ac over 2a so you always end up or if
this is a positive number you end up
with two solutions and they're equal
distant right there this far away this
far over 2a away from negative B over 2a
we could write this as negative B over
2a plus or minus the square root of b
squared minus 4ac over 2a so you get you
have at most two solutions that are
equal distant from this x value right
here now we've seen in multiple videos
what is that point that is equidistant
from the two solutions that is right in
between well that's going to be the line
of symmetry or the x value of the vertex
so this is where the x value of the
vertex formula comes from x Val of
vertex is negative B over 2a so if we
wanted to find the vertex the x value of
this guy right here we just take
negative B which is negative 3 over 2
times a 2 times 2 which is 4 so that X
is equal to negative three-fourths is
the vertex of this parabola and when X
is equal to negative three-fourths what
is y well we could actually let's see
that's a little bit more complicated
right here well I'll just I'll just
go through it it's going to be 2 times 2
times 9 over 16 2 times 9 over 16 minus
9 over 4 minus 6 let me actually get the
calculator out for this one well let me
see it's going to be 18 over 60 maybe I
can well then let me just get the
calculator out it's going to be simpler
don't want to waste your time doing
arithmetic so we get 2 so let me just
it's going to be 18 divided by 16 minus
minus 9 divided by 4 9 less now 9
divided by 4 minus 6 is equal to
negative 7 point 1 to 5 so this is equal
to negative 7 point 1 to 5 so the vertex
occurs when X is negative 3/4 it's when
X is right there and Y so let me do this
in the blue color because this is the
blue graph and Y is negative 7 and this
is essentially 7 and 1/8 so 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 point 1 2 5 so it's a little over 7 so
it's right there so the vertex of this
of this top graph is right over there
and it's symmetric around the vertex
it's symmetric around the vertex so that
is the line of symmetry and so this top
graph is going to look something like
this is going to look something like
that
just like that and we're done we've
found our two points of intersection
right over there and right over there
and when you graph it it looks looks
pretty good